hello everyone uh my name is steve shee
and i'm currently an assistant professor
out in concordia university in montreal
canada
uh it gives me great pleasure here today
to speak to you about some of the work
that my lab has been working on uh
specifically in the areas of gene
editing
uh microfluidics and automation and so
the title of my talk today
is uh gene editing uh by a click of a
button
and the way i sort of design my talk
today is through these learning
objectives
uh specifically through them uh defining
current paradigms of gene editing
identifying bottlenecks in the process
of gene editing
and then i'll sort of describe some of
the solutions that we came up with
to automate approaches uh towards gene
editing specifically in the area of uh
microfluidics
and so what i'll do is i'll start with
uh defining current paradigms of gene
editing
and you know for those of you that don't
know how sort of gene editing works
uh the idea is that you essentially want
to edit a specific gene that you want
uh essentially what you have is this
cas9
enzyme or protein that's kind of shown
here in the yellow
and the special part about this cast
iron protein is that it acts like a
molecular scissor
that will cut the dna uh essentially the
one that you actually want to edit
now the special feature though with this
sort of cast nine
is that it just won't cut anywhere uh it
actually recognizes
short dna sequences called pam as you
can sort of see
uh the label there on the screen and it
serves as a tag
and at the same time it actually sits
adjacent to
the dna sequence that you actually want
to cut out
now to actually guide the cutting or
guide the cast
you have also something called a guide
rna which actually
binds to the complementary dna target
that you actually want to cut
so essentially gene editing if you want
to perform it in your own lab
all you need is the actual protein the
cas9 and the guide rna
but once you know you actually have it
cut
you you create this double strand of
break what usually happens
uh actually in the cell and uh the the
problem
problematic sort of thing that happens
is that the cell's natural repair
mechanism starts to kick in
and starts to introduce these mutations
now one of the ways that they try to
introduce mutations is through this
non-homogenous
end-joining technique uh which
essentially is nucleotides being
inserted
or deleted uh into sort of the region
that's been cut
and this essentially induces any sort of
mutations or errors
and essentially disrupting gene function
overall
uh the other way where it's more
controlled where we have this con
homology directed repair mechanism and
it's essentially
filling the gap with a sequence of
different nucleotides
and usually this is a short strand of
dna uh
that acts as a template which can be
supplied by usually the scientist who
wants to perform the edit and this can
overwrite sort of any mutations
or incorrect uh errors that are are
represented after the double-stranded
break
and this whole system of crispr cast
now you can essentially use these
methods to perform gene knockouts
uh knock-ins uh precise base editing
for a number of different applications
like diagnostics is very popular
uh generating or producing different
cell lines
and also deciphering different pathways
like cancer
but gene editing i mean it's taken off
so quickly
uh but essentially what is the main
challenge that we have
uh with gene editing now i would say to
explain this
i want to first go through the process
of gene editing
and so essentially when you want to
start gene editing the first step that
you would do
is that you want to select uh
essentially a cell line that you
actually want to edit
edit the genes then you want to design
the construct
or specifically the guide as i explained
before
that will target the gene that you want
to cut next
you want to actually deliver this
construct into the cells that you
are into the cells that you want to edit
uh and then this can be done with a
number of different techniques such as
electroporation lipofection squeeze
techniques
uh then once you have inconcubated the
cell has sort of
taken over its mechanisms and then
performed the actual edit itself
then what happens is that you need to
perform some sort of selection
technique like antibiotic selection or
facts and then sort
to obtain these cells that actually have
been edited
but once you sort of gathered this
homogeneous populations
uh then you want to obtain the actual
single clone
and that's usually done with some sort
of constant pipe using techniques like
limit dilution
or calling picking techniques and then
finally
you can get that single clone place it
into a well plate
or some sort of platform like a well
plate you can expand the cells
and then use these expanded cells to
sort of validate
uh if the editing actually occurs but
having all this the main challenge still
is
what is what is that uh the main
challenge here is that the techniques
actually that are involved
for genie editing actually needs to be
optimized
uh transfection selection and soaring
single cell cloning
validation expansion all these different
steps
all require different technologies to
actually perform their tasks
and this actually contributes to a lot
of variability in the results
especially in between different labs
that are performing the same type of
editing
and this really poses many challenges to
really fully automate these processes
particularly around you know
transfection efficiencies
uh enriching and recovery of single iso
clones
and because of this uh this pipeline can
take
months at a time for you to get the
actual single clone or the edit that you
actually want
it can incur much higher costs and at
the same time it requires frequent
uh manual intervention and so what we
propose in my lab or what i'm going to
show you
is that microfluidic systems can
actually miniaturize these experiments
uh you can multiplex them in parallel uh
reducing the cost increasing the
throughput but the main advantage is
that we're able to integrate
and fully automate these gene editing
steps
into sort of one platform and the
technologies that i'll focus on today
you know i don't have a lot of time to
discuss all the different types
but i'll focus mainly on the
droplet-based technologies
where mainly the droplet and channel
technologies
uh the digital base uh microfluidic
technologies and i'll also combine both
technology which refer to them
here as hybrid microfluidics so now what
i'll do is i'll take some time to
describe both these technologies
starting with digital microfluidics for
those of you
that are not familiar with digital
microfluidics essentially it's a
a liquid handling technique where we
manipulate droplets on a rave electrodes
a unique feature with digital
microfluidics is that you can manipulate
droplets
uh on an open or closed face surface
and as you can see from these images
here you have lots of
uh or have the opportunity to control
these droplets has
individual addressability which allows
you to
dispense these droplets into smaller
droplets with excellent precision
you can move them you can merge them you
can mix them and split them as
as well but how this how does digital
microfluidics all work
is that essentially you have the side
view of a device
uh you you have these metal electrodes
that are patterned on a glass substrate
uh you deposit an insulator a
hydrophobic layer
and then you would put a droplet on top
of the surface which is now
then covered with the top plate counted
electrode
which contains like also a hydrophobic
layer now typically you can manipulate
the droplets in air so nothing
surrounding the droplet
but you can also have some sort of
filler fluid such as oil
which sort of minimizes sort of the
friction between the droplets
and the surface for for the actual
droplet movement and if you want to go
into more detail
essentially how it works is that you
have these electrostatic forces that are
coming into play
essentially is like if you have like a
comb that you're brushing your hair
static electricity starts to develop and
if you bring it to a stream of water you
can start to see it bend
uh towards the cone and so by using this
sort of physical phenomenon
uh you can essentially switch you know
on and off these different electrodes
and then essentially position these
droplets anywhere
on the array now one of the main
advantages though
i would say with digital microfluidics
is that you have this
amenability this opportunity for
automation
uh there's no valves or pumps here as
you would have with
you know traditional base microfluidics
but what you have with this automation
system
is that you have this matrix board of
containing switches
and these can be essentially directly
connected
uh to the device itself so that you can
turn on and off
the different electrodes as i sorry
explained previously
now since this is sort of an automation
conference i'll kind of show you in more
detail
what this automation system really
consists of uh essentially you have this
user interface
that controls a microcontroller to
control all the switches that i showed
you before
and then you can also control the
voltages the the frequencies that are
needed to actually manipulate the
droplets
now if you are using you know
traditional base microfluidics you can
also include syringe plums too
as a plug-in into the system but
essentially all these stuff
all this sort of uh different parts can
be sort of
placed into uh essentially a box
that can be controlled by a software
interface that we have created
in our laboratory but anyone can
actually create their own software to
control this
this hardware system as well now the the
software that we have created
is that you can have your device design
essentially on the screen
where essentially it matches the
electrodes on the device
and then you can press or or create
sequences such that you can activate the
different uh potentials on the device
and then you can also create specific
functions as
you can create those fencing functions
mixing functions
merging functions of the droplet and
essentially this all be translated
all into uh moving the droplets onto
your device and if you're interested in
learning more or wanting to set up your
own microfluidic system for automation
you can find a lot of the code and
software and how to build the hardware
on on on our bitbucket website
uh shown here now just talk briefly
about droplet and channel microfluidics
as you know
uh digital you're you're working with
the rave electrodes but here you're
putting droplets inside the channels
uh you have a two phase system that
usually consists of an aqueous flow
and an oil based flow and then you can
essentially create droplets through this
t
junction shown in the left image here
and then you can have this hydrodynamic
focusing where you can create many
droplets as well
uh shown in the right image here now i
would say some of the differences
between digital
and and droplet is the following is that
a lot of droplet and channel papers or
in the literature
you you'll see that they have very high
throughput you could probably generate
thousand droplets at the same time
but often all these droplets here are
manipulated in series
and so the key challenges i would with
drawblind channel
is that there's a lack of control if i
want to generate a thousand droplets
and i want to access maybe the 100th
droplet that becomes very difficult i
would have to wait
for all the 99 droplets to pass by at
the same time droplet edition
uh it's very hard to add or add reagents
add media
add buffers add drugs uh to the to the
other
uh with other droplets and so it's
really difficult to
create a dilution series of droplets
but with something like adding the
controllability that digital
microfluidic offers
and adding the throughput that dropline
channel offers we can create some of
these the
hybrid microfluidic devices which now
you have both the advantages of
controllability
and throughput so here you can see from
the images you can
essentially merge different droplets
anytime you want to
and then here you can store you know two
types of droplets like shown here as
green and red
but you can have many different sorting
channels here right just show binary
but in the paper that we have from
fatima ahmadi we can store many
different
droplets at the same time so now i sort
of given you guys
some of some ideas about gene editing uh
what are sort of the bottlenecks in the
process of gene editing
uh now sort of go into some of the
automation or microfluidic automation
approaches
on how we can actually edit the or gene
edited some of these cells
now before i do that i just want to
explain that uh there's sort of a
mismatch
between uh between microfluidics and
cell culturing if you want to edit cells
the first thing that you need to do
is that you need to make sure that you
can cell culture
but if you if you've done cell culturing
before you know that
cell culturing likes hydrophilic
surfaces but what i explained before is
that digital microfluidic systems they
actually have a hydrophobic system
so because of this mismatch you know it
poses a challenge on
on sort of how we sort of culture cells
and therefore how we can edit cells
downstream
but uh during my sort of uh graduate
school days uh we were able to come up
with a system
where we create this hydrophilic site on
a digital microfluidic device so instead
of having
uh a constant a hydrophobic layer
on the top plate we create this
hydrophilic site and by doing that
what you can see from the image on the
left here is that you can create these
miniaturized or smaller droplets on
these hydrophilic sites
and then because of that uh you can
create these miniaturized droplets but
at the same time you can have these
adherent cells
start to adhere onto the surface or the
top surface on the device
while allowing uh to manipulate the
droplets using the bottom plate
of the digital microfluidic device so
with this in mind
uh one of the first pieces of work that
we did in my lab is to try to implement
sort of the
uh first steps of gene editing on on
digital microfluidic device so here i'm
going to
try to explain to you uh the four steps
that we've implemented to manipulate the
droplets
so i'll go into sort of the device
design uh show you how we validated our
device
and we did a proof of concept actual
knockout and then we also showed an
application where we automated
proliferation assay so i'll start with
uh the device the design so what we have
here
again is that we're working towards
automating this workflow
where we have first starting off with
the plasma design
we perform the cell culturing the
editing and the actual the data analysis
to see
which ones have been edited and which
ends have been knocked out etc
and so here we would take these last
uh three steps and integrate them on the
uh digital microfluid platform
and sort of here is the device design
that we have and it consists of two
key features or two key components on
the device
one we have a region where we can
prepare the lipid complexes for
dna or rna or protein delivery uh this
will be used to
essentially deliver uh the cas9 and the
guides directly into the cells
and then we also have cell culturing
regions where we have this
hydrophilic spot where we can allow all
these cells to actually
culture on the top plate and so what
we've done
is that we we took the timeline that is
needed to
edit the cells and then we followed a
number of different steps so here we
would see the cells
uh where we create droplets by
dispensing them on the digital
microfluid platform
so you can see from the images here on
the left panel you see
like sort of the gui interface that we
have and this is matching
uh the drawable movements that you see
live or
images that are from a live movie of of
showing the uh
travel movements on the device and so
you can see the first step is we
actually see themselves
uh step two we actually combine the
lipids and the dna
so that we can actually deliver them to
the season cells
uh then we would incubate the lipid
complexes
uh to create the lipids with the dna
inside
uh we can dilute them as well to create
many different concentrations
and then finally we would actually
deliver the lipid complexes to these
uh hydrophilic spots uh you can add
drugs
in the meantime you can maintain them uh
and then you let it incubate such that
you can determine the transfection
efficiencies
or you can outgrow them determine the
knockout efficiencies or you can
actually continue
to perform an assay directly on on the
device
and so the first step what we've done is
we actually took
uh lung cancer cells uh as a test to
to for for the editing now as you can
see
on the left panel here you uh or the
left image you see that these lung
cancer cells are actually green
uh of course lung cancer cells are not
usually green so what we've done
is we integrated this green fluorescent
protein
inside the cells and then the first step
what we did was we created a guide that
actually knocks out
these green fluorescent proteins now one
of the first steps we did was we
wanted to check if the viability and the
morphology
uh between our device versus traditional
well place
if there's any differences as you can
see here just from
uh looking qualitatively of what the
cells are looking like
on the hydrophilic spot versus the well
plate we don't really see
much of a morphological differences uh
which means it's promising that we can
sort of continue
sort of going through the genetic
process downstream
so the next thing that we did was we
actually performed the
transfection on the chip now one of the
first problems that we faced
when we're trying to do the actual
transfection
as you can see is that there's a high
confluencing when there is a high
confluency of the cells
the sellers start to overlap with each
other which makes them very hard to
count
uh through through imaging techniques
and especially if they're fluorescent as
you can see here
some are very dim some are overlapping
so
then we have this problem where we're
unable to actually count the cells and
this because this
is a problem because downstream if we
want to look at efficiencies
uh we're not sure how many cells have
actually been transfected how many cells
have actually been knocked out
compared to the starting population uh
on the device
and so a solution what we did or what we
came up with
is that we created this automated
pipeline to actually
accurately measure the transfection and
the knockout efficiencies
and so here's just a brief overview of
our our
transfection pipeline and essentially
what we did is that we labeled
the cells with her stain which labels
all the nuclei
the nuclei of all the cells and then we
will look at an m
cherry image where when we transfected
the
the plasmid uh it has an m cherry
reporter
and by masking the objects together we
can then sort of calculate
which ones have been transfected and in
looking at gfp
we can actually figure out which ones
have been knocked out
so we did some preliminary experiments
where you know we've created different
dilutions
of the lipid complex versus media ratio
and as you can see as the higher ratios
uh one to one there are usually needed
for a higher or more efficient
transfection on the chip
at the same time we also compared if we
tried different incubation times
and then we compared them to the
standard technique of wall plates
and what you can see here is after 48
hours we achieved the highest
transfection efficiency around 70 and
this is promising
such that you know we're seeing you know
very good similarities with the
the traditional platform on the uh on
the well plates
so next we want to sort of evaluate or
show
uh gfp knockout so again we just took
uh uh or created guys that served low
or targeted three different locations on
the gfp gene
and what we found is that efficiencies
for both knockout
uh on the well plate the traditional
platform and our digital microfluidic
device for very similar
and that we're achieving around 48 and
we use
to to get this number we use the
standard imaging pipeline
uh for the analysis so we have again the
gfp
uh we stain the cells with her stain we
mask the images together and you can see
some of those some of those cells that
are there but don't have gfp
and then we count them as sort of a
knockout and that's how we obtain
our our efficiency
so then uh we went on to sort of perform
this
microfluidic automation sort of
proliferation assay
and what we did is that we want to
evaluate
uh the potential of our using our
platform for gene entities so what we
did is we explored
uh this relationship between gene
function and cell phenotype by studying
a cellular pathway
uh specifically we looked at the erc and
map k or the kinase
kinases pathway and as you can see the
raft genes and the ras genes
are upstream uh to these components of
the
kinase signaling cascade and so
therefore we use
because of this they're essentially
nodal points in self
perforation flagging them as potential
or potent occle genes
and so we use them here as essential
targets so the guide that we created
would target raf1
and then we also added a drug something
called seraphinitos late that would
inhibit
the expression of b raf and also raf1
so what we did first is that we sort of
looked at four different conditions so
we transfected
cells under these four conditions as
already you can see is if you provide
genomic disruption you can start to see
a decline
in sort of the cell viability uh on the
and so you see reduced proliferation
uh on the second day you would add the
drug so what we did was we added
stereotosylate
and you can see further decline into uh
the uh the cell viability or or the cell
health uh
for the ones with the guide and the drug
and then if you
you continue on to let it outgrow over
several days
because we do see uh sort of a
heterogeneous population
we do see some increase in the growth in
some of the conditions
but the main point here is that with the
drug
and with the genomic disruption you can
start to see
a much lower uh or increase in cell
deaths
or and much lower in cellular viability
and we sort of proved this too
by looking into this dose response curve
where we had the inhibitor
and also genomic disruption and here we
observed that genomic disruption lower
doses levels
are capable of reducing the cell
viability
essentially what we're showing here is
that the combination of genomic
destruction
and enzymatic inhibition uh leads to
cell death of the
the cancer cells so this is really nice
is that we essentially showed that
we can uh automate the transfection
automate the cell culturing
the editing and then finally automate
the assay and also the analysis of
whether if it's been transfected uh also
automate the efficiency of
transfection and knockouts as well now
if i refer
back to the pipeline uh so again the
problem arises to
you know he's done the transfection
we've done the editing but now how do we
actually achieve
you know selection sorting of the clone
that we want or you know how to isolate
the single clone how do we expand
we still have this heterogeneous
population so what do we do here so
uh how do we get to this sort of single
clone
and so what we've done is we created a
device another microfluid platform where
it combines
the droplets and digital and we sort of
use
this idea to trap the cells or to
capture the cells
uh have in-situ droplet generation and
then
actually select the clones clones that
we want through imaging techniques
and so again uh here's the sort of the
platform that we use
for selection and isolation it's this
three-layer device that will provide the
control
has this on-demand functionality where
you can select the droplets anytime you
want create droplets anytime you want
and at the same time we have throughput
as well and really all it consists of is
the digital microfluidic layer
the dielectric for the digital
microfluidic layer a channel layer for
the droplets
and then a pms lab to essentially
provide the reagents and as well prevent
any sort of evaporations of
the liquid but just to remind you again
all this
can be done with automation by just a
simple
interface uh with our graphical user
interface
and essentially you can create sequences
or functions
that you can just essentially click and
then be able to
automate the drop of movements on our on
our device
so to give you more detail our device
consisted of two parts
one part is that you can create this
on-demand droplet generator
and so essentially here you can generate
mono dispersed droplets of different
volumes on demand
and so we compared it to you know the
typical hydrodynamic focusing
uh way of generating droplets and you
can see here
essentially you can have a range of
volumes that you want with the on-demand
uh generator in the second part we can
essentially
uh trap the cells uh create the droplets
in situ
release them or keep the droplets and
essentially using these sort of
functionality we can then isolate the
single clones
now i'm going to talk to there's
actually essentially five steps that we
need to actually get your edited clone
but here what i'll do is only go through
a few steps to kind of give you an idea
of um of how we actually get the edited
clone
for sure you can if you're if you're
still have more questions you can
definitely email me or look at the
publication
but here i'll start with the second step
where we essentially trap the cells from
the heterogeneous population
uh we take that population load into the
syringe and then flow it into
uh in our device where it essentially
traps the individual clones
uh we tried different flow rates and as
you can see sort of from
our our characterization is that you
know with five nanoliters per second
as a flow rate we can achieve the
maximum efficiency of our device around
88
which is great once you've had once you
track these cells now you encapsulate
with the droplet
the next thing you can do with their
device is that you can have this
on-demand functionality
to release them anytime you want and so
here i show you a series of
images from a movie uh that shows the
actuation sequence to release the drop
on demand so you can see the droplet is
trapped the the two red dots
represent the activated electrodes then
you can essentially drag the droplet
anywhere you want
and here is just kind of showing you
what it essentially means that here you
can see the cell
that's trapped in in in the region
and then you can release them using
electrodes uh any direction
you would like by doing this uh the key
thing here
is that you could release it through
hydrodynamic focusing
uh using a range of flow rates you can
see that some it
relies on the flow rates to have sort of
this probability of likelihood of
releasing
but having this sort of on-demand
regardless of what flow rates you use
uh you can you can have this on-demand
release which is essentially
perfect and it doesn't have to depend on
sort of these these flow rates which is
really nice
so essentially if you want this clone
you can essentially
release it anytime you want
now once you release the clone the next
thing what we want to do
is actually recover it uh so what we did
was we followed this method from joe
hanson's room and published his last
technology where
essentially you have this uh single cell
droplet covered with oil
you put this on the ptfd device mix it
with media
the ptfe acts as a way to absorb the of
the oil
and then you expose you remove the oil
from the droplet and then you can take
that droplet
and place it into well plate for further
expansion and then
finally further uh verification and so
if we sort of summarize of what we've
done
essentially what we we can do is in in
terms of time
is that we can actually knock out this
the specific
uh genes we can trap them encapsulate
release
and then recover them uh except
recover all these isoclonal cells in a
matter of 45 minutes
as opposed to uh hours or or months to
actually perform this whole
pipeline and so if you want to do work
on this whole pipeline
you can use both of our devices and it
takes one week
approximately i would say one week to
perform the actual
transfection selection sorting isolating
the single cell
and validating an expansion as well
so with that uh i think i'll summarize
my talk
uh i hope i've shown you that we're able
to automate the gene editing pipeline
uh using on-demand droplet-based
microfluidics uh we've expedited the
workflow
uh to less than one hour for trapping
sorting and recovering cells
usually approximately a week for the
pipeline instead of a month
and at the same time uh you can download
our
hardware and software for your own
implementation and this is available
at our share above bitbucket website and
at the same time
i have one of my former students has
started this company called drop genie
and if they're trying to automate
gene editing using microfluidic devices
and if you're ever
interested in learning more i suggest
you definitely contact hugo sinha
who's actually the ceo of the company
here
and with that i definitely like to thank
some people
uh definitely my first student uh hugo
who's not here in the picture but he's
now the ceo of drop genie
angela who was also the law of the cell
culturing
and also kenza family who did a lot of
the work for the
single cell isolation and of course a
lot of my funding sources here
and please if uh if you're more
interested in learning what our lab does
definitely check us out on
on our social media feeds and also if
you have any questions feel free to
email me
and i look forward to discussing some of
our projects with you further thank you